ich habe auch schon überlegt ob ich mal
eine tote maus essen oder leute hier
lest richtig im titel ich reagiere heute
mal wieder zusammen auf hilfen mir und
falls ihr hilft mir nicht kennen sollte
herzlichen glückwunsch ihr besitzt
wahrscheinlich noch alle von euren
gehirnzellen das hier ist die folge auf
die wir heute reagieren werden gibt's
mädchen meine freundin denkt sie ist
eine katze ja bevor wir uns die folge
anschauen würde ich sagen gucken wir uns
mal die kommentare an wir zehn minuten
lebens verschwendet er sagt auch nach
jeder folge das war das letzte mal er
möchte auch dass luca darauf reagiert
gehe hier in zellen werden vernichtet
prinz ich glaube paar von uns sind jetzt
reif für die klopse alter ab schon lange
nicht mehr so hart gekämpft ich weiß
nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen soll wer
zur hölle schreibt diese texte wer
wartet auch auf lukas reaktion
die kommt jetzt
okay wir sind es 55 sind wir in dieser
folge und wir sehen direkt dafür hätte
erwerben was du machen kannst du dir in
sich fortpflanzen wollen wow
er war wie gesagt machen katzen sich
verschlossen worden
ich habe monatelang nicht auf eine
einzige folge hilfe reagiert und
direktor komisches ganzen medialen
ich habe keinen bock auf die katze ich
will meine frau und hör auf mich hier
irgendwelche waltz sind sofort zu tanzen
ich versteh gar nicht was du hast hat
sich doch total niedlich und ich dachte
[Musik]
mein hut verkleidet ist dass sich warum
dass mich das nicht eine kuschel mission
sein dass der ausgang so muss es erstmal
auf handy muss wieder normal werden
system sie arbeitslos ist sie so komisch
und seltsam drauf aber ich bin mir katze
benötigt verstehe ich echt nicht
also hat eine arbeitslose kürzer als
freundin menschenrechte sind ziemlich
abstoßend macht mich wahnsinnig ich bin
ich bin reich für die klapse da kommen
die kosten machen können jetzt nein nein
jetzt sie spielt darauf nicht absehen
würde in köln bei mir.de man auf
bürgersteig dann eher würde ich aber er
später das ist jedoch eine schale
mädchen stellen dass das nicht wahr
die machen sich scheiße das aussieht
davon dass erinnerst du dich dann auch
so
ach ja das ist ja auch dazu kostüm
ich weiß warum ich monatelang nicht auf
hilfe reagiert habe wenn rafael an ihr
okay also ein falls ihr seid hier auf
meinem kanal beziehungsweise allgemein
mit der serie hilft mir noch nicht so
ganz vertraut sei die haben ab und zu
immer eine tolle meinung in der serie
mit drin von einer therapeutin und in
dieser folge geht es ja um katzen
von daher haben die sich gedacht ja dann
setzen wir die therapeuten doch einfach
mal ein hund offen auf dem schoß
komplett ins schwarze getroffen aber mal
schauen was die therapeutin so zu
berichten hat es könnte sogar sein dass
diese offene ablehnung ihr verhalten
noch weiter verstärkt a
da bin ich jetzt aber wenig gespannt bin
ich da was für das jetzt mal was macht
jetzt meine sachen
es ist nicht euer ernst oder doch die
meine sachen den müll schweiz gab ich
beruhige dich vor ort beruhigt sich uns
aber verändert zurück ich stehe dafür
euch mal es stimmt dass du noch wie man
sie kennt und
also stellt euch einfach mal vor ihr
wohnt da in berlin im innenhof und auf
einmal hört ihr so ein bisschen geschrei
und ihr denkt euch ja das sind die
nachbarn haben da ein bisschen stress
dann schauen sie den hof runter und sie
ist einfach eine katze die ja ich diese
echt nicht mehr zu retten da kannst du
dich hinsetzen
hast du schon eine katze gesehen die auf
der couch sitzt vernünftig komplett in
ihre katzen film drin mann der oft
machen sie kratzt das ist wirklich
probiert mit zum kratzen ja natürlich
das ist nicht aber das hat sich immer
als teil der auf der schleuder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du hast nicht mehr alleine aus der
schleuder ich sag's doch noch sprichwort
raphael us verhalten ist ein beweis
dafür dass es sich immer mehr in ihre
katzen existenz hineinsteigert geil
liebes hilf mit ihm
da könnte ja auch mich hinsetzen da sage
ich dann auch einfacher ferner ist eine
dumme katze ich finds halt auch stark
wie der hund einfach null bock auf die
grenze kaka hat in dem albernen trotzdem
nicht 69 hat diese katze bin sollte
verdeutlichen oder was
es kam zu lang
mehr gelaufen
raphaela muss die abweisung des
türstehers also akzeptieren
aber ob sie deshalb ihre katzen
verhalten ablegen wird werden wir sehen
ich bin jetzt mal gespannt was die
anderen leute vor dem club davon halten
dabei wettzumachen bekommt
jaspersoft ein kitz hinauf dies ja
lebensgefährlich alter wird so zum
einschläfern lassen
habt ihr noch gehirnzellen will hier ist
gut wenn du mich nicht meine beste
freundin wärs dann wird ihr hinter mir
stehen aber ein glück habe ich das team
weitere leben unter blechen apple lernen
sieben weitere leben
lasst mich in ruhe was mich nicht mal
das sein kann trotzdem uns nur ärger
macht ja also ich bin auch dafür dass
die raphaela dass das rwe und sensibel
wirklich wieso sagen wieso pfalz setzte
also ich habe ja schon einige kreative
beleidigungen gehört aber holzköpfe also
das verbiete ich mir hier rede hat er
bei mir in die kommentare holzkopf
schreibt der dmv sich an
dadurch dass raphaela sich als katze
fühlt gelten für sie andere gesetze sie
muss ich keine arbeit suchen und kann
sich benehmen wie sie will
bei echten tieren sowie joy ist das
niedlich also megacool dafür sieht er ab
heute noch mal sagt was für sie niedlich
ist nämlich der hier und sie anscheinend
nicht das ist diskriminierung gegenüber
katzen dass er bringe ich jetzt zur
anzeige
[Musik]
hey ich dachte keinen scheiß leute hab
ich gedacht da kommt jetzt ein schöner
übergang mit einer schönen
hintergrundmusik und dann kommt
vielleicht noch ein paar schöne bilder
aus berlin oder irgendwie soll da kommt
dass die trinkt hat jetzt tatsächlich
ihre katzenmilch wisst ihr was ich mich
mittlerweile frage richtig gar nichts
mehr und nicht weniger auf's spiel setzt
sich hin ja der auch weil es schon
wieder getan presseportale aus
ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß wer wohin mit
meiner nerven ich reißt jedoch auch
nicht deine barthaare raus raphaela das
ist eng
was machst du
ich musste mal was musstest du was muss
man hier ist ein clown ging an java
karten aber hör auf mit dem kürzen kann
man zocken und mir schloss ende hat
schon sein kopf hin gelassen hätte also
eher geht's noch das ist rwe wenn alle
absoluter lieblingsserie das heutige
video ist allerdings ob meine lieben
freunde wird euch dieses video hier mal
wieder gefallen hat also ich hab ja
wirklich monate lang nicht auf hilfe
mehrerer geht dann lasst einen daumen
hoch unter diesem video hier das
schaffen wir 50.000 namen hoch ich weiß
es ist eine menge
aber wenn ihr wollt es sich mal wieder
öfter auf hilft mir und andere serien
reagiere dann lasst einfach ein like da
schreibt es auch und in die kommentare
eventuell soll ich ja mal was anderes
reagieren als hilfe auf eine andere art
von serie oder auf eine andere hilfen in
folge also das könnte mir gerne und in
die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr noch bis zum 17 etwas im luca -
shop.de bestellt dann geht ein euro
eurer bestellung an die stiftung gegen
rassismus also mich würd's mega freuen
wenn ihr da mal vorbeischauen würde und
abonniert main kanal so dass ihr in
zukunft keine videos mehr verpassen
werde
[Musik]